[Музика]
привіт привіт всім мене звати Наталія
команда, настав час уроку англійської мови, давайте
розпочнемо, тому сьогодні ми продовжимо розмову про
фільми та кінематограф і в основному зосередимося
на оглядах фільмів, але перед цим давайте
перевіримо домашнє завдання, яке я попросив вас
вибрати правильні слова для  речення, тож
давайте вже разом перевіримо, так що номер
один головний акторський склад або
персонаж грає Крістен Стюарт
яка правильна відповідь
це персонаж, тож давайте прочитаємо
речення ще раз головну героїню
грає Крістен Стюарт номер два
фільм найкраще знятий  або певна Канада,
правильна відповідь встановлена. Дія фільму
відбувається в Канаді номер 3 Хоббіт
отримав хороші відгуки про троянду або субтитри від
критиків, а правильна відповідь - троянда
зараз відгуки Хоббіт отримав хороші відгуки
від критиків
номер чотири Сучасні фільми мають дивовижні
спеціальні технологічні блокбастери  ефекти
так, це факт, тому сучасні фільми мають
дивовижні спецефекти, і номер
п'ятий фільм виходить на екрани або sh
сьогодні правильна відповідь виходить,
фільм виходить сьогодні, а останній
Сурадж Шарма зірки
місце або прямий шпигун у Житі Пі
правильна відповідь місце Сурадж Шарма
грає ПІ в Житі Пі, тож давайте перейдемо
до кіно та різних типів
фільмів Я хотів би почати з
цитати, і це зображення може допомогти
вам подивитися, у нас є різні кольори
і кольори дивляться в різних
напрямках, що це означає,
наприклад, я люблю червоний колір, але ви можете сказати, що
мені не подобається  червоний колір мені подобається жовтий,
і твій друг може сказати, що він або вона
любить синій, а твоя мама тато любить
фіолетовий, тому ми в основному говоримо, що всі
люблять різні речі, і ми можемо сказати, що
тестери знову відрізняються, тестувальники відрізняються, це
означає, що всі люблять різні
речі, які
я люблю  комедії, але ви любите дивитися
драми, наприклад, тож давайте сьогодні поговоримо про
різні фільми, і у мене є завдання
для вас подивіться Я отримав повідомлення
від мого друга, і вона пропонує подивитися
кілька фільмів сьогодні і  щоб я був
зайнятий, вона надіслала мені квест,
вона надіслала мені смайли, і їм потрібно
вгадати фільм, тому це завдання для вас
спочатку, а потім я розкажу справжній
фільм, готовий, Алок,
що це за фільм, у нас є фільм номер 2
це вже згадувалося на
початку нашого уроку, це номер 3.
Ми говорили про цей фільм на попередньому
уроці, а цей я впевнений, що ви
знаєте відповідь, готову перевірити, тому у нас є
фільми про Гаррі Поттера, фільми про Джеймса Бонда,
фільми про Хоббіта та фільми  Життя Пі, то
що, на вашу думку, є номером один так,
майже очевидно, це
фільми про Гаррі Поттера люблять дивитися
фільми про Гаррі Поттера, мої діти любили це, і я також насолоджувався
ними
наступний так, це життя Пі
номер три, я думаю  ви знаєте відповідь,
це фільми «Хоббіт», а
останній це Бонд Діна, тому
фільми про Джеймса Бонда давайте рухаємося далі, тому ми вже
обговорювали огляд фільму про Джеймса Бонда,
давайте нагадаємо, що це в останньому
фільмі про Джеймса Бонда «Скайфол», який
вийшов на екрани  У 2012 році вважається
найкращим фільмом про Бонда наразі, у ньому знявся Деніел
Крек як двічі-о-сім,
і я думаю, що всі погодяться, що він
чудово
грає, сам фільм сповнений пригод і має
чудовий саундтрек, ту саму мелодію  була
виконана Адель, яка сама написала пісню,
загалом, Skyfall — чудовий фільм, де деякі
люди думають, що він занадто насичений екшеном,
але саме тому ми дивимося
подвійний о-о-сім, чи не так, тож це
огляд фільму про Джеймса Бонда, давайте
подивіться ще один, який
ми обговорювали під час попередньої розмови про «
Хоббіта», давайте подивимося на «Хоббіта»,
пам’ятайте, що я запитав у Дерека та Наталю
про фільм, що вони пам’ятають
з історії, ось що вони згадали, з
чого ви пам’ятаєте  історію
давайте перевіримо
я дізнався, що Пітер Джексон режисер
«Хоббіта» Я також дізнався, що він був
знятий за допомогою спеціальної техніки, яка називається
технологією високої частоти кадрів, яка означає,
що глядач бачить 48 кадрів в
секунду замість 24 кадрів  дізналися, що це
дає набагато більш чітку картину, тому давайте
перейдемо далі, подивимося на деякі популярні
фрази з інших фільмів, я повернусь,
що це за фільм так,
це Термінатор,
тому у Х'юстоні є проблема, ми
згадували цей фільм раніше, тому
як це там називається Паоло Сатін, давайте
перейдемо, подивіться на цей діалог чи ми
там ще
немає ми ще немає як ми там
ще так насправді ні так добре звідки
це анімаційний мультфільм під назвою frac я
впевнений  ви пам'ятаєте, що якщо ви не
дивитесь фільм англійською мовою, і я впевнений,
що вам він сподобається, то давайте поговоримо
про життя Пі, це
огляд історії, я хочу, щоб ви послухали і
зловіть відсутні слова, подивіться  у нас є
певні прогалини і спробуємо вгадати
слова, а потім ми разом перевіримо,
послухаємо й спробуємо записати слова готові,
давайте вперед Життя Пі — це фантастичний фільм,
заснований на романі Яна
Мартела, який отримав приз, у головній ролі Сура Шарма у фільмі
Головна роль Пі Пателя у фільмі - це
історія виживання  val у відкритому морі під час
плавання з Індії до Канади корабель П.І.
тоне в жахливому штормовому пирогу, він
опиняється посеред океану з
кількома тваринами, включаючи лютого
бенгальського тигра,
вони повинні зрозуміти, як залишитися в живих
у відкритому океані, який поєднує фільм
реальні сцени із зображеннями, створеними
комп’ютерами, як сюжет, так і
спецефекти чудові, тож якщо ви
не вловили слова, ви можете перемотати
і прослухати історію знову, а потім
перевірити у нас зараз, давайте подивимося на
їхню відповідь  давайте подивимося на
відповіді, щоб у нас був весь текст, чи
хотіли б ви прочитати зі мною «Життя Пі» — це
фантастичний фільм, заснований на
романі Янна Мартела, який отримав премію,
у головній ролі — Суреш Шарма у головній ролі П. І. Пателя
у фільмі  це історія виживання у
відкритому морі під час плавання з Індії до
Канади. Пиріжок у формі пирога тоне в жахливому
штормовому пирогі, він опиняється
посеред океану з кількома тваринами,
включаючи лютого бенгальського тигра, вони повинні зрозуміти
, як  щоб залишитися в живих у відкритому океані,
фільм поєднує реальні сцени з
зображеннями, створеними комп'ютером, і
сюжет, і спецефекти
блискучі Я дивлюся цей фільм Я дійсно
рекомендую вам переглянути його знову, це
дуже приємно,
тож давайте перейдемо далі, перш ніж слухати
більше відгуків і людей, які говорять і
описують фільми я хочу представити два
нових слова для вас подивіться на
картинку назва фільму
називається коти що це за тип фільму це
не комедія це не фільм жахів це
не  мультфільм, тож ми бачимо
виступ на сцені і
багато музики, тому ми називаємо фільм мюзиклом.
Отже,
коли у вас є дорога, і вона розділена
на дві частини, тому вона розділена, або ви
були у стосунках, і ви
вирішили розлучитися, тому ми називаємо це розділенням,
тому пара розлучилася або дорога розділилася, а
тепер давайте перейдемо до вправи  тож ваше
завдання полягає в тому, що ви почуєте
розмову між двома друзями про
фільми для кожної людини один два три і
чотири це Саллі Браян Філ, а
завтра, будь ласка, виберіть тип фільму, який
вони бачили, і напишіть правильну літеру
abcd або e у полі  один тип фільму
не відповідає жодному з людей, тому
це зайве, нам він не потрібен, перш ніж ми це зробимо,
це типова вправа для
прослуховування, тому ми бачимо завдання, і перш
ніж почати слухати, нам потрібно пройти через
типи  знімає два ключових слова і подумайте
над словами, які ви могли б почути під
час розмови, тож давайте передбачимо,
що буде, якщо ми побачимо слово
комедія, тому комедія, що ми можемо почути
в розмові, поки люди
описують комедійний фільм,
ймовірно, сміються  сміх смішний або будь-які
інші слова давайте перевіримо, що я тут маю
смішний сміх смішний сміх або жарти
давайте перейдемо до наступної
дії, що ви можете знайти в бойовику,
що ви чуєте, як люди говорять,
описують у цьому фільмі action-p  acked
adventures насильство іноді боротьба або
добро і зло давайте подумаємо про мюзикл
що ви чуєте, коли люди говорять про
мюзик, ймовірно, музичне виконання де
ще саундтрек, можливо, давайте подивимося
та перевіримо партитуру музика танці, а також
інструменти співи та пісні давайте перейдемо
до драми, що може  у нас є тут те, що
ми можемо почути, люди говорять про драму
сумно зворушливий гнітючий драматичний емоційний
і плачуть і останній фільм жахів,
які прикметники чи слова ви можете
почути, поки люди описують фільми жахів,
мабуть, плакати, ймовірно, страшно страшно
давайте Хамрлік страшно страшно боїмося
моторошно жахливо добре, тепер ми готові
до завдання на прослуховування, тому давайте виконаємо це
знову,
ми слухаємо розмову
двох людей і маємо чотирьох людей,
згаданих у діалозі Саллі
Брайан Філ, а завтра зверніть увагу,
що їм подобається комедійний бойовик музична
драма ahora there is  Буде ще один
додатковий пам’ятати, готовий слухати,
давайте привіт, Саллі, як твої вихідні
о  привіт, було дуже зайнято, насправді
в суботу вранці я мав хокейну практику,
а ввечері пішов до кінотеатру
з кількома друзями, ми побачили справді чудовий
фільм, який називається Forever One, справді, я теж був
у кінотеатрі в суботу,
але я не подивився  не бачу цей фільм, це
комедія, ні, це мюзикл, це було дуже
приємно, ми не могли перестати танцювати на
своїх місцях,
тож який фільм ви добре бачили, я любив свого
брата Брайана, але
нам було неможливо вибрати фільм, який би ми обидва
хотів побачити, що він великий шанувальник бойовиків, тож
ти хотів побачити зіткнення кулаків, але я
хотів побачити останню драму з
Деніелом Дей-Льюїсом, тож що ти зробив добре
врешті, ми вирішили розділити обидва
фільми були на  у той самий час, тому ми
щойно зустрілися біля кінотеатру, а
потім у мене така сама проблема з
моєю сестрою Тамарою іноді в суботу,
наприклад, вона вирішила залишитися вдома
і подивитися фільм жахів на DVD замість
того, щоб приєднатися до мене в кіно.
у всіх різні смаки, зараз
добре  перевірте, що подобається Саллі, що
її улюблене, і ви можете сказати мені, що
це мюзикл, давайте перевіримо, давайте
послухаємо речення, про яке вона згадала про
це, ми побачили дійсно чудовий фільм під назвою
назавжди, це мюзикл, тому ми знаємо,
що вона бачила мюзикл і  правильна
відповідь - C, давайте перейдемо до того, хто такий Браян,
яка правильна відповідь для Брайана так,
це дія, давайте перевіримо
речення з діалогу, але
нам було неможливо вибрати фільм, який
ми обоє хотіли побачити, він великий  шанувальник
бойовиків, тож ми чуємо, що він великий
шанувальник бойовиків, тож правильна відповідь
Б давайте перейдемо до Філа. Філ — це
людина, яка бере участь у розмові, тому
що йому подобається так,
він любить драми, давайте перевіримо, чи було
речення з діалогу  але я
хотів побачити останню драму з Данте Луїсом,
тому він хоче побачити драму з
Деніелом Дей-Льюїсом,
давайте виправимо завтра, так що їй подобається, так,
вона любить фільми жахів, давайте перевіримо, у
мене така сама проблема з моєю сестрою
завтра, тому  інколи в суботу,
наприклад, вона вирішила залишитися вдома і
подивитися фільм жахів на DVD, тож
правильна відповідь - e, а
у нас немає комедії.
Я впевнений, що ваші відповіді були правильними,
якщо  ви хочете послухати знову, просто перемотайте назад
і спробуйте ще раз, давайте перейдемо до вікторини,
я збираюся трохи перевіряти вас, тому
готуйтеся до питань, у нас тут є
список речень, 13 речень, і вам
потрібно вибрати правильний пункт,
правильний  прийменник головним чином, тому всі ці
речення взято з відмов, які
ми обговорювали, я даю вам час, тому ви
зробите це самостійно з запискою,
а я збираюся зробити це на дошці, а
потім ми разом перевіримо готові  давайте
[Музика]
тепер давайте разом перевіримо, щоб ви
мали готові відповіді. Я маю готові відповіді,
але я зробив тут три помилки, тому,
будь ласка, перевірте, що правильне, а
що неправильно в
порівнянні  на ваші відповіді і ви
вже можете мені сказати, що Наталія № ф
наша не правильна, це ще не так, реклама
неправильна, давайте подивимося книга
про виживання у відкритому морі, а що
щодо наступної помилки, а це
номер 10, так що номер 10, який
неправильний, фільм розповідає історію всіх
відомих  і є ще одна помилка так,
це речення під номером 13, скажи в
невірному Хоббіт оживляє зараз
давайте перевіримо разом
це правильні відповіді,
давайте поговоримо про речення, які ви можете прочитати
зі мною. Фільм заснований на чудовій
книзі  Основна частина історії відбувається
в Африці
Мартін Фрімен грає роль
Більбо Беггінса в «Хоббіті» книга про
виживання у відкритому морі історія
починається, коли корабель тоне під час
жахливого шторму, ми пливемо на острів
на  човен Я не можу
відрізнити реального тигра від
тварини, створеної комп'ютером, я подружився
з Енді в перший день у школі
документальний фільм про один день із
життя режисера фільм розповідає
історію відомого  американський  президент «
Залізна людина 3» вийшов у 2013 році фільм
був знятий з використанням комп'ютерних
технологій, а останній «Хоббіт»
оживляє фантастичний світ
Середзем'я — це дуже корисні
фрази для огляду фільму, який ми
збираємося написати  це наступний урок, тож підготуйтеся, що
ваше домашнє завдання до наступного уроку – це
перш за все переглянути словниковий запас з
уроку 1 до 7 і вибрати фільм для
перегляду до наступного уроку,
наступного разу ми проведемо урок письма, тому будьте
готові переглянути  словниковий запас і
підготуйтеся до корисних фраз, ось і все
на сьогодні є дзвіночок, і нам потрібно
припинити урок, дуже дякую, до
наступного разу
[Музика]